mais ce que je voudrais comprendre je
voudrais avoir des explications sur la
réaction de les réactions négatives à la
déclaration de François milterran qui
insistait sur la nécessité de créer une
grande organisation socialiste pour
discuter avec le le Parti communiste le
problème de la création d'un parti
unique de la fusion disons entre le
Parti socialiste et la convention des
institutions républicaines n'est pas
notre affaire comme vous venez de le
dire c'est c'est votre affaire à vous et
nous nous n'y voyons aucun inconvénient
vous avez envie de participer mais bien
sûr on a tous envie de participer à la
vie la vie c'est c'est à tout le monde
alors on est dans le cou moi je suis un
nouau mais enfin ce que je fais je le
fais et ça sert à tout le monde quoi
comment on peut justifier que les
conseiller communiste de la ville de
Paris est décidé unanimement avec les
autres conseillers que la place
desétoile soit appelée à l'avenir place
du Général de Gaulle le groupe
communiste d'ailleurs avait même proposé
que la décision soit pas prise tout de
suite que sur le principe il y a un
accord la décision du nom de la rue soit
renvoyée à plus tard notre proposition a
été repoussée et c'est là que les
camarades ont avancé et bien il y a qu'à
appeler la r royale r du général de GA
notre proposition a été repoussée B
j'aime bien entendre les autres
personnes poser des questions tiens ça
m'intéresse parce que les questions que
les gens posent ici dans la salle
peuvent mêtre posés à moi dans la rue et
je dois pouvoir
répondre moi je pense d'abord que les
meetings traditionnels comme vous dites
B c'est une forme d'expression du Parti
communiste et d'autre part ces
discussion avec avec la population par
exemple de Nanterre ici c'est une une
autre forme de discussion avec la
population le première assemblée débat
qui avait été organisé dans la région
parisienne les camarades qui avait
préparé cette assemblée débat avait
recherché le le moyen d'intéresser les
gens de voir que précisément dans cette
formule il y avait quelque chose de
nouveau alors ils ont recherché une
formule et on a trouvé cette formule
dites-moi monsieur marché ou en direct
avec George marché ou d'ailleurs vous
pouvez remarquer que selon lesassemblée
Desbat les les les les les formules
changent mais il s'agit de de bien
accréditer l'idée il s'agit d'assembler
débat libre où on peut poser toutes les
questions vous avez vu tout le monde a
posé la question chacun a posé la
question qui lui a semblé la meilleure
et n nous sommorcé de répondre à toutes
les questions